Thanks so much. I'm just, after
I started work on this book,
I went to see one of the greatest scholars
of the 17th century and he'd written
some of the finest pages about Salem
and I wanted some advice. Well,
I left him that day. We're standing
on the front porch of his house. Um,
he added another little piece of advice
pretty much as an afterthought. Um,
he said, I should probably warn you
that when you write about witchcraft,
really strange things happen to you.
Um, and I kind of forgot about that.
Like the comment disappeared in the
air and I went on to research the book,
write the book. I finished it more or
less on schedule, kind of more or less,
maybe sort of approximately on schedule
at the publisher was really happy with
it and they were even happier when they
learned that publisher's weekly was
going to do a profile of me this summer,
um,
with which they would run a full bleed
full page picture. And indeed they did.
And here's what it looked like.
So as you may notice that
Stacey Schiff is not, I, um,
thanks to Twitter.
It took me about 90 seconds to figure out
that it's Amy Stewart, a novelist too.
I've never met.
She does have a book out this fall about
which I'm thinking maybe I could cross
promote and when I asked my publisher
to send me this page so I could show
people what strange things happen
to you when you work on witchcraft.
I also asked them to send me the
table of contents. Um, and here it is.
I don't know if you can read it, but, um,
essentially I was rather surprised
to learn that after four years in the
archives unearthing and deciphering
and squinting at documents,
corralling my imagination, the hiring
fact checkers, I had written a novel, um,
saw strange things obviously do happen
to you when you work on witchcraft.
This is not a book of fiction.
Um, instead it's a temp,
an attempt to grapple with exactly what
happened in eastern Massachusetts in
1692 among the loop iest really
certifiably strangest moments in American
history. Um, seller may
qualify as the best known,
at least understood chapter in our past,
partly because it seems so improbable
and partly because it comes to us through
Hawthorn and through Arthur Miller
who were in fact writing fiction.
Here we are halfway between Plymouth
Rock and Paul revere and suddenly
everything just goes
screamingly off the rails. Um,
allows them as well also make clear
in the course of nine months. Um,
we go from one very deep one kind of
story to a very different kind of story is
a tragedy to which we go back regularly.
A few corners of American history
have been so often explore it.
And if you don't believe me, take a look
at this. Here's my local libraries, um,
stack of 17th century American history.
So you can imagine me crawling my way
from eating my way from one end to the
other. Um, this, the other
side is my office shelf.
When I finished writing the book,
you can see there at the very top there,
those little low classical
library of volumes.
Those were leftovers from the
Cleopatra Years. And I'm just,
I've always wanted to,
what Cicero thought about being a wedged
between the puritans on both side of
him. There Salem is a little
bit our national campfire tail.
It's one of the rare moments
in our history when the
candles are knocked out and
everyone seems to be
groping around in the dark.
That's where all good
stories begin in the dark.
We imagined most vividly and we believe
most fervently it's in the dark and we
contemplate our mistakes
and wrestle with our fears.
In the dark goes the Italian proverb,
every cat is a leopard and if you read
the court papers at 17th Century Essex
County,
which I spent a lot of time doing,
you begin to notice that the
new Englander lived very much,
very attentively and very
apprehensively in the dark.
Women tend to stumble into their beds
to find strange men sleeping there.
Men trip home through the
night to discover that
familiar landmarks have moved
and then people get lost
in their own backyards.
Young men report that they're weak kneed
at the thought of riding home in the
night to their families after sundown.
And when the devil offers to
accompany them, they accept his offer.
I read every 17th century account of the
New England merch of the wolves howling
in the distance and the
lurking native Americans.
But it took me a really long time to
figure out how dark dark truly could be.
And in truth, it took me until this,
this is midtown Manhattan in 2012, um,
in the wake of Hurricane Sandy,
I was driving some friends
home to their home downtown.
We were up town and we had electricity
and suddenly all those accounts of the
New England wilderness made sense.
I mean, you couldn't see anything.
You could truly become
disoriented, um, in your own yard.
And hence the line in
chapter one of the book,
The Sky Over New England was crow Black
Pitch Black Bible black, so black.
It could be difficult at night to keep
to the path so black that a line of trees
might freely migrate to another location
or that you might find yourself pursued
after nightfall by a rabid black hog,
leaving you to crawl home
bloody and disoriented on
all fours. That's by the way,
from the court testimony,
the basic facts of Salem are simple.
In early 60,
92 over a particularly cold winter,
a nine and an 11 year old girl
began to shutter and scream.
They happened to have been the niece and
daughter of the Salem Village Minister
Samuel Parris. Here he is,
um, he would have been in his
late thirties. At the time.
The cousins complained that something
bitten choked them. Their bodies twisted.
They would attempt to fly through
the air and climbed down wells.
We have lots of descriptions of the,
of the afflicted girls,
the bewitched girl's symptoms. Um,
but we obviously have no image.
And here's the closest
that we can really come.
This is a 19th century French text on
the phases of hysteria on the emotional
trauma and what its physical
manifestations would've looked like.
Remember that no one in the 17th century
distinguished between an overtaxed
nervous system and be Wichman.
The first question anyone asked in the
face of these kinds of symptoms wasn't
for some time would remain MIB witched.
Um,
it was understood that any kind of
prolonged fit had been sent by the devil.
And indeed within,
within a matter of weeks to other village,
girls begin to exhibit the same symptoms.
Everyone's soon learned from their
parents or from local authorities are from
Reverend Paris that they were bewitched.
And with that was the diagnosis.
You can very well imagine what came next.
The girls symptoms seriously
deteriorated soon enough.
All four of them could
reveal who'd be which thumb.
We don't know why they
named the names they did.
But when you think about it for a
second to the question, who irritates?
Who annoys you? Who unsettles
you? Who wish, who wishes you ill?
Every one of us has an answer.
And so did the girls at the
answer to that question. And 60,
92 was clear.
It turned out that there were not
one but three witches flying around.
Salem warrants went out.
At the end of February for their arrests.
The suspects came immediately
before the authorities.
Justice was very swift
in the 17th century,
and they were interrogated
in the manner of the day,
which meant that a local beggar woman,
the first woman to be deposed,
was asked by the justices when she
had signed a contract with the devil,
why she hurt the girls,
what creatures she had dispatched to do.
So those questions came to
her from very well dressed,
important men who own
significant businesses who
spoke with weight and authority.
The contest was asymmetric.
And I should say that this is a story
that has something for everyone.
And here you can see it begins
to mutate because it turns from,
it begins as a kind of fairy tale.
Once upon a time,
a wicked witch cast a spell on a little
girl and it turns very quickly into a
courtroom drama.
Let me talk for just a few minutes about
how witchcraft worked. Um, what exactly,
uh, which was, um,
not every 17th century new
Englander was clear on the subject,
but those who were, were exceedingly
clear to the early American,
which existed as plainly as did
heat or light at the early American,
which I should add, did
not look like this. Um,
although there is a certain wizard of Oz
theme running through the Salem story,
and I'll talk about that in a minute.
And nor did a 17th century,
which looked like this. This is by the
way, the original, if you can believe it,
the original wicked witch
of the West from the, um,
from the book that wizard of Oz.
I particularly like those, um,
that flying pig tail on the spats, which
are kind of unexpected for a which, um,
this is an early American Halloween,
which you can see that which is
came very late to, to Halloween. Um,
and they didn't dress and basic black
until after Margaret Hamilton and the 1939
wizard of Oz,
the witches,
a 17th century new Englander knew her
with someone who could perform unnatural
feats because if the compact that
she had signed with the devil,
and from that pact, she drew her power
to transform herself into cats, wolves,
rapids,
and of course rabid black hawks,
which could be a man or a woman
the more often she was female.
And she maintained them,
maintained a menagerie of imps or
familiars who could do her bidding.
And those mascots could be
turtles are weasels, um, cats,
dogs and toads are very prevalent. As
you can see here. This is a 17th century,
which who is feeding blood
to her diabolical toads. Um,
this is a woman who has her diabolical
familiars with her. It's her.
You can see her black cat,
of which there are a great number and
her demon familiar and Sheila's straight
to 1621 English witchcraft case. But, but
this woman actually was acquitted, um,
at her trial. Here's some
more diabolical familiars. Um,
you see that they range from
the sort of standard issue,
barnyard pig to rather gargoyle
like, um, fantastical creatures,
black cats, um, particular favorites.
They seem to have been the arch enemy
of man from the very beginning and they
turn up regularly throughout
the Salem testimony.
They said they've enjoyed an association
but the devil for a long time.
Black dogs turned up a lot too, but
historically English, which is, um,
tended to prefer feline to canine
form. This by the way, is not a,
which is familiar.
This is our family cat moose,
but I hope she's looking sort
of vaguely demonic here. Um,
but which signed her pact with the
devil and blood and she enchanted with
effigies and ointments.
She could be a muttering,
contentious malcontent or she or he
could be simply strong or unaccountably
smart,
both kinds of,
which is what turnoff in 1692
as would wealthy merchant,
as would wealthy merchants who are,
which is sea captains,
who are witches ministers and homeless
five year old girls who were witches.
While her power was supernatural,
the witches crime was a
religious one in New England.
Her target was the soul rather than
the body and her connection to the
convulsing Salem girls.
According to the legal guide on many
Salem desks in which was about to land on
Samuel Parris, his desk, this is
the volume by William Perkins.
Witchcraft when it manifests, it showed
up as senseless trances, paralyzed limbs,
convulsions, jaws, clamped, shot,
frothing, gnashing, and violent shaking.
In other words, the symptoms of the
girls in the parsonage to a tee.
When Massachusetts
established a legal code,
the first capital crime was a dollar tree.
The second was witchcraft.
In the years since those
laws had been codified,
New England had indicted about 100,
which is a quarter of whom were men.
They had hanged. Massachusetts,
however, had hanged only six aside,
the mystery of the girls symptoms
in Salem is a greater mystery.
Why in 1692,
the hasty and the merciless prosecution,
the charges were very familiar
from earlier witchcraft cases.
Casting spells on livestock was
a fairly common one in Salem,
which is cast spells on cattle. On Hay,
out of wagons. I must get some fireplaces.
They sent dishes, sailing
through the air. Um,
why you might ask her these
women riding on a pig. Um,
this is from an early English witchcraft
trial they had been at keeps women,
had been accused of be witching
the pig, um, New England,
which is do not do a great
deal of flying down chimneys.
And they do do Kirito flying down
chimneys and through apple trees.
And ultimately they will
fly to a satanic Sabbath.
But I should say the traditionally
the English which did not fly, um,
continent continental witches,
however we'll fly and that will give us
a clue as to what's about to happen in
Salem. And also, um, there had been,
there were ghosts in 1692 who tend to
flit in and out of the Salem courtroom
most,
but not all of them are women who have
come back to then judge themselves on
abusive husbands. Those two can
hook, do confess to witchcraft.
And there are quite a number will confess
to having flown either on the devil's
shoulders or on Poles or on branches
are on sticks. No New England,
whichever flies on a broom, I'm sorry to
say. Um, these are some English flyers.
Um, there seem to be recruiting
the woman on the ground here.
This is an 18th century woodcut.
However, as far as broomsticks go,
this one is my favorite. Leave it to a
French woman to be able to fly gracefully.
This is a 14th,
15th century French set of witches.
The accepted phenomenon on
witchcraft basically went like this,
which has existed everywhere in the world,
in every culture and how is
it possible that imagination,
which is so varied and so unpredictable
could deliver the same idea across all
cultures in all times? In other
words, witchcraft was so preposterous,
so improbable. It had to be true.
You just couldn't make this stuff up.
The first arrests in
Salem surprise nobody.
The suspect's counted among the likeliest
people to be voted off the island.
And let me talk just for a minute about
the next person accused the fourth
accused witch for a few reasons.
I think part of what fascinates
us about 1692 is the random,
the seeming randomness of the accusations.
What if the next knock landed on your
door? In the case of Martha Corey,
a very pious,
stiff spine farm woman in her sixties.
We know what happened with that.
When the knock landed on her door,
it was mid afternoon on March 12th.
Um,
she'd been named by a 12 year old village
girl and it surprised everyone because
she was a full church member and very
devout because she was the church deacon
and another man went to pay
a call as a courtesy on her.
And first they stopped off to see
the little girl who had accused her.
They asked if she could
possibly be mistaken and
could she describe what Martha
Corey had been wearing when she afflicted
this girl? I think the child's did.
She couldn't because the,
which had blinded her that morning,
but she would be back that evening to
torture her some more. The men rode off.
They found Martha Corey alone at her
house. She welcomed them with a smile,
but she also anticipated their question.
I know what you are come for. She said,
you are come to talk with
me about being a witch.
She was not a witch and she
couldn't stop people from gossiping.
How do we know all this? By the way,
this is the deposition against her, um,
which the two men will write out after
they've visited her with that day and
they tell her that the girl has,
um,
has deemed her the first
question Martha Corey asks is,
but does she tell you
what clothes I have on?
They were flabbergasted by that question
because of course it was precisely what
they had themselves asked.
And they seem to think that she had
some supernatural knowledge. Um,
she was sure that there
was no cause for concern.
She had nothing to do with
witchcraft as everyone knew.
She was a very devout woman.
She wasn't surprised though.
She said if the devil had recruited the
first three women, in her estimation,
they were malicious,
slothful people.
And interesting thing about Salem is
that even those who insist on their
innocence, who believe in their innocence,
think that the others are witches.
Martha Corey,
that afternoon promised that she would
open the eyes of the magistrates and the
ministers so they might
find the real witches.
Another comment that would
backfire within the week,
not only her 12 year old accuser,
but that girl's mother was
also afflicted a spectral.
Cory nearly tore the
older woman to shreds,
offering her a diabolical pact
to sign the warrant for Martha.
Cory's arrest went out immediately.
This is it.
She was accused of having committed
sundry acts of witchcraft on a grown woman
and on for youngsters. One of them
Reverend Parris, his 12 year old niece.
That note that you can see in the bottom
and the different ink is the Salem
constables confirmation that he's
arrested her and that she's in custody.
And this document is dated March 21st,
but because the sabbath was the next day,
she in fact couldn't be
arrested until Monday,
which left her time on Sunday to go
to church along with her accusers.
So before the pulpit that Sunday,
you have five spellbound girls and
women and one which suspect, um,
all of them in close proximity
in a tiny building. Um,
this is a reconstruction of the village
meeting house. It measured 34 by 28 feet,
and you can see how dark it
would have been inside. Um,
it wasn't always possible during the
hearings that were held here to identify
the suspects indoors. They often had
to be taken out into the daylight.
And when the minister began the
service, um, the march service,
he was interrupted by the
afflicted girls in the pews.
One pointed to the ceiling.
She claimed she could see Martha
Corey sitting not in her seat,
but up in the beams nursing a
diabolical canary. The next day,
Martha Corey returned to the
same room to defend herself.
It was thronged with spectators.
There was a palpable terror in the room.
A visiting minister said that he could
nearly make out the hammering hearts.
The raised hairs on the backs of the neck.
Martha Corey insisted on her innocence.
One asked one of the justices asked
the question that not on every mind,
how had she known that she would
be asked about her clothing.
She tried to explain,
but she was interrupted.
Generally 17th century courtrooms
were not orderly places.
The girls frantically pointed
about the room. They could see,
they said the devil whispering and Martha
Cory's ear. What did he say to you?
Asked the justice she had
neither seen nor heard of thing.
We must not believe all that these
distracted children's say she replied to
which they refresh agonists. Did she
understand the meaning of distracted us?
The justice?
Because by definition,
distraction was fleeting and the girls
were utterly, utterly consistent.
Everyone he reminded her,
understood them to be bewitched.
He urged her repeatedly
to confess she would not.
One of the interesting things about Salem
I should point out is that those who
refuse to confess, we'll hang. Um,
which is to say that the most principle,
the most noble, the most steadfast people
will end up faring the least. Well,
Cory was pelted with questions, none
of which she could answer. Instead,
she posed a particularly plaintiff
query herself. Can an innocent person,
she asked be guilty?
I don't know if you can see it,
but this is the document of that hearing.
And the first question here is, um,
you are now in the hands of authority.
Tell me now why you hurt these persons.
And she actually asks if
she can pray a request.
Just start asking several times to
request, which has repeatedly denied.
She insisted she had nothing
to do with witchcraft. Um,
a statement that incents the crowd.
The girls began to yell and to snap into
Maka replies when she bit her lip with
nervousness, teeth marks bloomed
on the arms of the girls.
If she clapped her hands together,
the girls were began to shutter.
She leaned forward.
They would crumple over an agony.
It seemed as if she were working
witchcraft in the courtroom itself.
By this time, two adult women are
bewitched and the course of the testimony,
one of them or 40 year old
woman starts to howl in pain.
And she says that it's Martha
Corey who's attacking her.
So the woman takes off her muff from
our hands and throws it across the
courtroom. At Corey, it fails to hit her.
So the woman then leans over and takes
off a shoe and lobster shoe at Martha
Corey and hits her squarely in the head.
A pin that she had stuck in one of her
victims also turns up that day in the
hearing room.
Um,
pins will tend to turn up often
in Salem Pearson cans. By the way,
the Puberty Essex is collection.
These were taken over the next
weeks or purportedly. So, um,
from the girls' hands and legs,
um,
one girl turns up with a pin puncturing
her lips so she can't testify.
Blood will trickle from another girl's
mouth and a red stain will appear across
her bonnet in the courtroom. How do
we know all of this from two sources?
Um,
a former village minister was on hand
that day and published his account of the
trials and April,
this is the title page.
You can imagine that the account of what
was happening did nothing to alleviate
the symptoms. And we have a lot of the
paperwork to from this particular hearing.
Um, this is the deposition
of one of Cory's accusers,
a 17 year old girl
named Elizabeth Hubbard.
It seemed that Martha Correa had urged
her to sign a pact with the devil.
She bitten and choked and pinched her
and the girl had the bruises to prove it.
I believe in my heart, she testifies
here than Martha. Corey is a dreadful,
which, and as you can see that
some of this was added later.
The court testimony is interesting because
it's not infrequently edited, edited,
or expanded on after the fact. This
is in the hand of Reverend Paris. Um,
it's the local innkeepers deposition
against Martha Corey for having tortured
the girls at the hearing. And you can
see on that second and third line,
he seems to have written out the account
before he asked his neighbor to a fixed
his name to it. And a third line,
Martha Corey that day went to jail.
She would spend the next
six months in prison,
in chains and in prison awaiting her
trial. Six days after the hearing,
um, Paris will deliver this sermon
in the, in the meeting house. Um,
you can see it's titled Christ
knows how many devils there are. Um,
and when I mentioned documentation, by
the way, this is as good as it gets.
Paris was a very meticulous,
very diligent man and this is the
finest of 17th century penmanship.
So I want you all to feel sorry for me.
Um,
it's a finger pointing sermon after this.
It's basically you're either
with us or you are against us.
And the community really divides
between accusers and accused.
People begin to remember things that they
can't explain often decades old things
that they can't explain.
Men Begin to see their neighbors
flying through the streets. Um,
the evening after the first hearing to
villagers will meet an unnatural beast on
the ground which dissolves
in the moonlight. Two or
three women they testify,
materialized in its place and fly away
shortly thereafter behind locked doors.
One of them sits up in bed when a great
gleam and a big fat cat appears in his
room. Um, if this has happened
to any of you recently,
please let me know afterwards.
Um,
all of this testimony
was store sworn on oath.
It's all full of tall tales unless
you happen to believe as woman.
One woman reported after
having bout to tell the truth,
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth that she flew on a stick with her
church deacon and two others to a satanic
baptism and that the previous Monday
she carried her minister in spectral
form through the air along with her along
with her having previously conferred with
her in her orchard with a satanic cap
again and again what working on the book.
I kept thinking of Dumbledore in
the seventh Harry Potter book.
Of course it's happening
inside your head herring,
but why on earth should that
mean that it's not real?
The first case came to trial in June.
The first suspect hang do week later
protesting her innocence to the end events
to moved quickly,
arrests and afflictions multiplied.
It was a plague that involved a hundred
witches and number that grew to 307 and
later to 500 and here's
where the courtroom drama
will mutate again now into a
horror horror story,
not only for those who spent months
roasting and that starving and airless
fedded prisons.
Some suspects would die there and
others in chains would give birth there.
By late July,
the authorities begin to piece a
tale of a diabolical sabbath, which,
which flew to from as far away as
Connecticut by various conveyances,
all of them to land in Salem village
and all of them part of a conspiracy not
only to subvert the church,
but to subvert the state.
And according to Parris his daughter,
by the way,
Martha Corey also will
attend that meeting. Again,
you can reconstruct that meeting,
um,
and these rituals from at
least 50 core confessions,
but we unfortunately have no
image of the diabolical Sabbath.
Here's the closest we can come. This is
a 17th century German engraving of a,
which is Sabbath. Um, it's a more decadent
production than a new England one,
but certain themes are familiar.
They'll remember that I said there'd been
no flying in Massachusetts before 1692.
Well, suddenly by the summer, everyone
in Essex County seems to be a loft.
Um, here's an earlier illustration
from a Swedish witchcraft epidemic.
And from the book you'll see why
Sweden is hugely important here.
But notice that this woman is
flying with her children. Um,
in Massachusetts in 1692 girls of eight
or nine are accusing their mothers of
coercing them into signing packs with
the devil by late summer that didn't see
denunciations are flying in every
direction. Daughters accused mothers,
brothers accused,
sisters and parishioners will
accuse their ministers in Andover.
Nearly one in 10 people was accused,
including never.
Nearly every female member of the
town's senior minister servants accused
mistresses. Although mistresses
did not accuse servants,
no one ever suffered from witchcraft
without also being able to name a witch.
Martha Corey went to her death and
September 22nd and what would be the last
hanging before she hangs?
She's visited in prison by Reverend Paris
who will excommunicate her and this is
his account of the excommunication.
He's irritated that the prisoner
who was a very religious woman,
refuses to pray with him in the 17th
century. A prisoner also by the way,
paid for her his or her jail charges
for the blankets and the provisions.
This is the jailer is accounting
and you can perhaps see that.
The third item here was for
Martha, Corey and her husband. Um,
by September the colony
had executed 14 women,
five men and two dogs for witchcraft.
Somewhere between 140
and 180 had been accused.
And then as broadly as it had begun,
the which panic was over,
the questions that Salem elicits or
those of our nightmares can an industry
innocent person,
Martha Corey asked to be guilty.
Might I be a witch and not know it?
Another suspect asked,
could anyone wondered a group of men
late in the summer, think himself safe.
A Brash widow in our fifties came
before the justices in April.
She was not a witch. She refused. She
could not even say what one one which was,
she had the bad luck to be
appearing before a final magician.
How can you know that you are
not a witch and yet, no, not no,
and yet not know what a,
which is as the justice.
So obviously what we have on our hands,
not entirely a fairy tale or a courtroom
drama or a horror story, but a thriller,
presumably that line of trees did not
move from one side of the field to the
other. Presumably there were no
flies through the air killer cats.
There was no satanic celebration with a
long banquet table in the Salem meadow.
How then did these things happen?
When you begin to pry the
whole episode of part,
you see that it makes uncanny and
eminently modern sense and no,
I'm not going to tell you how that came
to pass the clues as to what drives
Salem forward and what will result in
an unprecedented 100% conviction rate.
The only for the only
witchcraft panic in our history,
our woven a strand at a time into each
chapter of the book and it's meant to
read like a thriller so that you,
you get the,
the idea that only at the end it's meant
to unspool with the logic of a dream
and the lucidity of the supernatural,
the unlikeliest of heroes will
emerge in the end. Um, no,
I'm not going to tell you who they
were either because that would make my
publisher on happy.
We go back to Salem again and again for
the same reason that it came to pass in
the first place.
The irksome lack of closure.
We share the villagers
need for resolution.
We go back to the trials for another
reason too though, as crack ups go,
this one council among the
more sensational in our
history to which so many
later missteps would be compared,
that is less on account of the scale
than unaccounted the circumstances.
The court in 1692 consisted
of the best and the brightest.
They lived in the finest homes
in their respective communities.
In 60 92 it's the state,
the broad light of day,
and the name of God led by the ablest
men and the colony who sent innocence to
their deaths. When friends and
acquaintances came before them,
those authorities doubted not
the girls but their own friends.
This is a portrait of Chief
Justice William Stoughton
who sat at the head of the
Witchcraft Corp,
and I will give you a hint and tell you
that he is not the hero of the story.
He was nearly as starchy as he looks here.
He's the most eminent New England
legal authority at the time,
and he will die at home nine years after
the trials without a word of regret or
apology.
He was the goto person for all legal
matters and 17th century Massachusetts.
No one was better versed in,
in legal code,
which points up something else crucial
about the panic are you addition plays
much more of a role in this
story then does ignorance. Um,
arguably the bay colony qualifies as the
best educated community in the history
of the world.
Until that time,
the New England ministers here increase
in cotton Mather, the father and son,
to whom any number of civic authorities
would appeal for guidance had delve
deeply into the literature.
They had devoured libraries on the
subject of witchcraft. If anything,
they may have read too much today.
Of course the trials endure
as a sort of moral guardrail.
This is where Salem mutates,
yet again to become a cautionary tale.
They stop us when we overreact
or over correct to me.
When fear tends to overpower reason,
they make the experts seem less expert.
They remind us of the risk of
thinking ourselves. Exceptional.
Satan's appearance in Massachusetts seem
to the New England administry like a
badge of honor, further proof that
new Englanders with a chosen people.
That statement resonates in troubled
times. We naturally look for terrorists,
some traders, a secret agents because
they hate us for our freedoms.
I just want to add that CLM feels
deeply and eerily familiar in an age of
crowdsource stories as well.
I'm an oral culture bearers are remarkable
similarity to an internet one both
feet on indelible rumor,
neither has much use for truth and the
Internet turns out to be a brilliant tool
for sewing conspiracy theory.
Things went viral in the 17th century
two and today we couldn't be two places
and two people at once as well.
Just as Martha Corey could
simultaneously be at home,
minding her own business and
at the parsonage pummeling
and choking the children
at Salem is hard.
There's a sort of fairy tale or are
these rippling sexual undercurrents and a
lot of terror. It's really about what
we see when we close our eyes. Um,
and about how those images can
turn for one thing and to another.
It touches on what's unreal,
but by no means on true for all concerned.
It's a story about, um, everyone's
agendas and everyone's secret agendas.
The girls, the justices, the ministers,
everyone's trying to accomplish something
here, which is not what he states,
what he states that he has
accomplished his goal. Um,
there would truly unsettle us those
agendas just as they unsettle the 17th
century new Englander who met with
the Goblin or the rabid pig and out of
reasons the early American turned to
witchcraft for an explanation out of
reasons. You are of course
supposed to turn to a book,
which I hope you will enjoy.
Thank you.
I told you may have questions or
comments or corrections for me.
Hi, my name is Laura. Um,
I had seen something once PBS,
maybe, I can't remember where,
talking about one of the theories
for what happened in Salem, um,
being not just the hysteria of the girls
but also potentially a fungus that may
have affected the mentally curious as to
what your thoughts are on that. I love,
yeah,
there's a,
there's a theory that the rye supply
had been poisoned and that a holistic
agenda that a fungus
that causes hallucinate,
Jay Hallucinations had grown and it was
a great and incredibly elegant theory,
but it, which has been largely
discredited for two or three reasons.
The two foremost ones being that the
girls are strangely terribly afflicted at
sometimes and perfectly normal at other
times and they tend to be the convenient
times like when they're asked to do
housework or where they need to testify in
court. And other times they seem to sleep
like babies and be perfectly normal.
So that doesn't entirely hold
up. Also, if the, if the,
if the grain supply had in
some way been contaminated,
certain members of the household,
uh, everyone would've been affected.
In this case,
you often have like has family,
there are three unaffected children
and then there are two girls who were
convulsing. Um, one of
them is then sent away,
but it doesn't affect the household.
You're gonna universally and also
apparently was the wrong season for such a
fungus to have grown.
But,
but I love that theory because it
would have put a bit been so neat.
Excellent.
I have a couple of questions and you can
actually refer me to the book if that's
better.
But first,
what became of the girls who were the
original accusers here in second of all,
historically sort of how much
time did it pass before people,
uh, properly came around
on this and said, you know,
the witchcraft stuff is
something in our imagination.
How long was that before that was
generally accepted in society?
That's great though to read questions.
Let me start with the second one.
What's really interesting about the
end of the trials is that the accepted
wisdom seems to be that they
have indeed murdered innocence,
but they also let guilty people go free.
In other words,
the belief in witchcraft
survived 1692 the belief in it,
perfect prosecution does not.
So the inpatients here is with
the way this has been prosecuted.
It's not what the concept of witchcraft
and it will take years still for
everyone to give up the belief in
witchcraft in 1693 cotton Mather less his
well-documented heart is taking clinical
notes on two more witchcraft cases.
Two more girls who invest in Boston,
um,
claim to be clear are
basically experiencing the
same symptoms and he knows
enough in 1693 to take those
notes and to document the cases,
but he says it's too vulnerable for
him to publish these things now because
everyone is still so because
the handover has been, um,
has Salem and Andover had been such a
terrific wipe out and there was so much
puddling guilt and shame over the,
over the issue.
Nobody will talk about
Salem for quite awhile.
But that belief that there is that
that belief in witchcraft persists.
The girls themselves,
um,
it's a difficult book to write because
of course I'm no 17th century girl kept a
diary. So we have the girls'
voices in the way in, in,
in how they converse with the devil,
which is interesting.
We place where they express
themselves the best when I,
the devil will bargain with them
and they'll speak back to the devil.
Those accounts of course come to us from
the male reporters in the courtroom,
so we have nothing that's actually
written in the girls own hand except some
testimony.
We have no diaries and we have very little
about what happens to them after 1692
one of the apparently does
continue to be in some way in from,
and it's very unspecific about
what continues to toward mentor.
The others go on to lead perfectly
normal wives and as I think I said in the
last chapter, they go on to get married
and have children, have families,
not necessarily in that order.
There's a strange amount
of having children out of
wedlock among the cohort of
girls who had been a flipped in 1692 but
most of them do seem to go on to lead
normal lives.
It's interesting because there had
been a case of possession of serious
diabolical possession
20 years before Salem,
and that girl who was done a grown woman
would have been alive at the time of
the, and the bother of a large family.
And I always wondered, you know,
what did she think of what was happening?
Because it could so easily have
happened in her case years earlier,
but the minister who had dealt with her
affliction had really been very careful
about con about containing
the crisis in that case.
Can you talk a little
bit about the research,
how long it took and where are you did it,
and just what the process was like?
Um, it took approximately 120
years. Um, it took, the research,
took him three years completely.
It took me about three years to research
entirely and then a year and a half to
write during which I was still researching
a little bit because of course once
you start writing,
you realize that you forgot to research
something or that you would need to know
more or you had just haven't gotten to
the bottom of something or you're just
obsessive and you need to keep researching
because it's better than writing
always. Um, so about, it breaks
down about that way. But Dot.
The trial documents,
these illegible beauties that you saw
or most of them at the Puberty Essex in
Salem and you know,
it's just astonishing because you know,
you're holding these papers that
would say so and so is, you know,
has been maliciously and feloniously
and wickedly practicing witchcraft in a
sentence to hang. I mean, they just
sent chills down the spine. Um,
they have a great collection.
Danvers has a terrific collection
because they have the church record book,
which I'm speaking to holes
in the narrative leapfrogs
over the entire summer as
does a lot of the documentation are huge
holes in the documentation. So great.
Was the regret and the shame in
the wake of Salem, Massachusetts,
torical society has
terrific stuff. Um, so does,
is it the new England historical
genealogical or s geological historic,
whatever it's called,
has great contextual stuff.
And the American antiquarian society
has a lot of the Mather material and
essentially what I filled in with other
17th century diaries and the quarterly
court records of the
years proceeding Salem,
which are really into giving you a
sense of what New England life was like,
what people's garages and antipathies
were, who was suing everyone by the way,
is suing everybody. This is the most
litigious society you can imagine. And,
and we're talking about litigation
that can last decades and slights that
reappear, you know, years
later. Um, it's just,
it gives you such a sense of
what people's obsessions were,
what the hot spots were that trespass
and drunkenness and fornication with the
big sellers. Um, there's
a lot of witchcraft.
There are number of witchcraft accusations
that go nowhere. Um, it's really, it's,
it's just, it's fascinating in terms of
giving you a flavor of New England life,
which obviously came in handy when
you're trying to explain the strains on
either a young girl or on
a civil authority in terms
of adjudicating something
like this. Another question. Um,
so I think one of the most
frustrating aspects of this stories,
this concept that there's no way
to really prove your innocence.
Um, I was curious if
there, and if there's,
if it's a spoiler you don't have to share,
but if there's any record of someone
actually rationalizing their way out of
being accused outside
of just being executed,
confessing or pointing the finger at
somebody else. Um, you put your finger,
I think on the thing that
kept me awake most nights,
which is that you're in a locked
room and you can't get out.
And once you're accused, basically
you're convinced the answer is no,
no one manages to get out of once accused.
Nobody manages to shirk the accusation.
There are two ways out. One,
and this was a very class,
plays a huge role in this story.
The wealthy managed to escape. And they,
most of them will escape to New York,
which the relations between Massachusetts
and New York at this point are,
are very hostile in New York.
Very happily. Takes them in.
And I kept thinking they were going
to be great papers in New York saying,
you know, those crazy puritans look
what they're doing to each other.
I never found them,
but most of the,
most of the fortunate people
who escaped to go to New York.
And the other way to get out of it
was to confess. And that's, you know,
it does beer have some,
without spoiling anything,
it does have some bearing on why you
have these unbelievably specific and
colorful confessions.
Because the more you confessed,
the happier the justices were, the more
useful you were in the prosecution,
the better you fleshed out this. And
Caribbean, you know, it's crazy story. Um,
and the confessors go back to prison,
but no confessor hangs.
So after a certain point,
it does become clear that it's
better to accuse than to be accused.
And it's best to confess.
So
they've told me an old
Sturbridge village that, um,
there weren't forests for the most part,
everything had been clear cut to be
used for buildings and heating and such.
What was it like around
the setting, um, uh,
150 or whatever years earlier?
Was it foresty because all the public
media presentations of I thought I saw
something, hey, where did
that person come from?
Or in a forest and sort of environment,
particularly when you have a low light,
when you have shadow we light,
it becomes a very easy to imagine things.
The demons in your mind basically become,
become more tangible.
Was it like that then?
That's,
that's also a great question and here's
where the court papers came in handy and
as did some of the captivity narratives
of which there are quite a few very
unforced did. They were,
had been a remarkable,
but basically the puritans arrived
and cut down all the trees.
There's the long and short of it
and it sounds familiar, right?
And today it's much greener and Lusher,
um,
in Essex county than it would have been.
Ben.
And I kept having to remind myself of
that with the help of the dam versus story
and Richard tracks because I would say,
well,
you can't see from this household
to the parsonage. And he would say,
but you could have in 1692 these
trees are a hundred years old. Um,
and you can see in the,
in the court records how much obsession
there was with timber because of course
without timber they can't build it
without what, they can't hit their homes.
And with, again, without
spoiling anything,
the Paris household is under particular.
It is a particular danger that winter
because it's up to the parishioners to
bring their minister firewood or they
don't like him and they're not bringing
him ward.
And it's a very cold winter and he's
shivering and he's talking about this from
the pulpit and he's basically saying, how
can you leave me without, without good.
I can't pray without pray. I
live, you know, when I will,
you will dispatch me to the other world.
And you'll have this on
your conscience is you know,
it's a pretty contentious relationship.
So yes,
the wood is a huge flash point as he,
as the trespass on other
people's yards to cut down.
Would that maybe isn't yours or the
carting away of other people's homes that
you know,
that you could use for the word and there
was a second part of your question. Oh,
if you were a lot about swamps.
Sorry,
what I was going to say when you read the
captivity narratives and when you read
about um, spectral presences
at this moment in Gloucester,
there are a lot of sightings of a spectral
band of Frenchmen and Indians and the
local militia is terrified because they
can hear these men, they see these men,
they can't find these men and
they're clearly just seeing things,
but they always arise from the swamps.
There's a lot of talk about the
swampiness of, of the landscape.
Very little about the trees. Um,
thanks. This has been [inaudible]
fascinating. I'm looking forward to
reading your book and I was just curious,
do you have any thoughts yet
on the topic of your next book?
If you're willing to share.
I was hoping you all were
going to bring that to me,
isn't that I thought that was
the transaction here. Um, no, I,
it's interesting this material is,
it does get under the skin in a way and
I have not entirely been able to emerge
from it. I keep servicing angles that I
wish I could play with a little bit more.
Um, and I'm not sure if that's the fault
of the material or of the tired and um,
Ondor downtrodden author.
But at the moment, no.
Um,
it sounding like the possible explanation
of sort of a combination of external
stresses and internal just quarrelsome
notice that seemed to exist.
You know, it may be a good candidate for
explaining all this, but I'm wondering,
um, and you've talked about some
of the possible external stresses.
I'm just wondering,
have people been able to develop
any personal motives in any of this?
In other words,
worse,
did some of the accusers have grudges or
particular quarrels or property issues
or anything like that against the
people that they were accusing?
I think in your book, I think you say
that there was a lot of just, you know,
even people within the same
family accusing each other,
which would argue against that.
But I'm sure people have done probably
you have done investigation about just
the more obvious motives that
might have existed and what, what,
what's the story on that?
It was a wonderful book.
Some of you may know which essentially
argued that this had been a property,
the whole thing had been a property scam
and that if you accuse the right person,
your estate would therefore,
um, flourish and it,
and it had a wonderful set of maps which
proved that the accusers were on one
side of town and the accused on the other
side of town and how this is how all
of the properties, uh, joined that too.
Unfortunately, it doesn't really hold up.
And it's also doesn't explain why you
have the intro family accusations or why
someone like Rebecca nurse who has
this extremely pious older woman who's
actually never been in court, which was
unusual in New England, gets accused.
It's possible that the fact people
thought the family had too much land.
It's possible that it's because all
her children lived and most people lost
children as possible.
That the family was simply to functional
and other people were jealous and we
just,
we do not know.
And so many cases why the finger is
pointed where they pointed the property
thing.
The only person who makes that well,
it terms of confiscating properties is
the local sheriff who was an extremely
tireless figure and managers
to be confiscating things
the minute anyone is put
in prison. But he doesn't, he
seems to have done it in a,
in a somewhat under the radar way and
he doesn't share his proceeds with the
authority.
So it doesn't,
it doesn't really hold up in terms of
some kind of conspiracy in that way. Um,
it is a number of forces to my mind.
It's a number of forces come together.
And I guess the one that I would talk
about without it being a spoiler alert is
the political scene,
which is that this is a colony
that's completely for three years,
has been living without government,
has a new government in place.
The strains of the chaos of the last
years are still very apparent and the
importance of establishing rule of law
in 16 in the summer of 60 92 was huge.
So for these men,
for the justices all of whom have helped
to topple a royal governor three years
earlier and are in disfavor of London
to prove that they are competent and law
abiding and law enforcing officials
plays an enormous role here.
Uh, I'm just curious like
your research process,
like the start to finish,
if you could maybe touch on like how
you kind of like the first thing you do
when you're starting to research a book
or like how that sort of evolves as
you're further into
researching the book and stuff.
Yeah. I'm, I'm really unscientific. Um,
which is to say if I'm
working on a biography,
which until now I had more living person,
I usually started with interviews because
I knew I had limited amount of time,
often with a particular
demographic, obviously with
a book like Cleopatra, this,
that didn't apply. So I tend to
go first to the primary materials,
which is possibly the wrong thing to do
because you're coming to them without
the context. And then I circled back
to them in the end. So I started,
I went immediately to the Peabody
Essex and read through the witchcraft
testimony.
I didn't know what to make of some of
it because I hadn't read everything else
yet.
Um,
I tend to confine myself to
primary materials wherever
possible because there's
just such,
I mean,
you saw those shelves and you could be
reading in those shells for 15 years and
never get to the end.
Um,
so my feeling is as little as like to
use the secondary materials as little as
possible. Um, things like
the pure at the sermons,
any 17th century direct
could get my hands on him.
I don't think there's one that I missed.
Anything that is 17th century
new Englander would have
known or read at anything
he wrote I needed to read.
Um,
and I don't do that in a
particularly scientific way,
partly because you don't really
know what you're looking for.
You haven't articulated your questions.
Yeah.
And then that ultimately of course means
that I end up going back to some of
those things once or twice again.
And you know,
the court testimony is a perfect example
of this. I read it once in the original,
most of it is published, 90%
of his published, at least
I went back to it again.
It is published form over and over again.
And then often,
not until two years later is that
I actually noticed that, you know,
when a particular person's testimony,
um,
she doesn't really give the
authorities what they're looking for.
She's just agreeing with
them and collaborating with
whatever w and agree with
whatever they've said. She's not adding
anything to their questions, you know,
it's a kind of thing that doesn't jump
out at you until you've read it several
times.
Um,
so I guess the answer to your question
is it's a kind of full immersion process
for me, but it doesn't
necessarily follow a linear line.
And with people like
Stoughton or the matters, I,
I can't read everything that math, no one
can read everything about others right?
Road. So I would read secondary
sources and I can find myself.
So that's actually a frustration.
But somebody like,
like cotton Mather who writes,
I think 92 books and the 69 he's alone.
You have to really limit yourself in
terms of what you're going to read. Um,
and those texts are really crucial
because you begin to compare different
accounts he gives or how he accounts for
witchcraft at different moments and how
his thinking of all.
So I tend to go back to the same things
over and over and read them more closely
rather than necessarily
spreading myself more broadly.
Thank you all.
Okay.